i never worried about
likeable or unlikable i worried about
trying to get him right which included
making the mistakes as big and as ugly
as they were
as
as authentic as possible
[Music]
dumb and dumber was a strategic career
move because i knew i could do comedy
and up to that point purple rose of
cairo something wild i'd kind of shown i
could do it but i wasn't a comedian so
therefore i wasn't allowed to do big
comedy movies this was no i can do
comedy let me do let me stand next to
jim carrey one of the best at it he had
had ace ventura had been out and been a
hit
and he had already just shot mask
hollywood knew the gym was about to
explode his next movie was going to be
dumb and dumber with pete and bobby
fairly studio wanted a comedian to you
know that's what you do in big comedy
movies and jim wanted an actor who would
make him listen who would react who
would get it's a buddy buddy movie jim i
said i can't a comedian will just try to
top me and then we're into that and
that's not what this is this is there's
a heart to this there's these two guys
they're stupid as hell but there's a
heart to them i got the role and i i was
aware that that others wanted someone
else but i knew that jim pete and bobby
fairly wanted me so we all went to
breckenridge colorado to start shooting
and the first day first morning we shot
the scooter me and jim driving down the
mountain pass and and i say i gotta pee
and he says just go man that was the
first morning first day pulling into
aspen supposedly and the snot coming
down getting off the scooter that was
morning one jim didn't work the rest of
the week we went to the lodge we did the
chair lift on the pole with the tongue
on the pole oh look frost
we did the tongue sitting there getting
pulled off we did
going into the ski lodge crashing the
skis jim's not working now we do the
snowball in the head now we get to
thursday and friday and jim hasn't
worked yet and i may be in dumb and
dumber but i'm not stupid the audition
is still going on i come to find out
they're going to assemble these scenes
featuring me and we're all somewhere
going to look at them over the weekend
and somebody
is on call somebody
who's a comedian is waiting to hear
whether he's going to go do the movie or
not nobody told me
but you could feel it maybe i'm just
hallucinating i don't know maybe i'm
being paranoid i don't know okay i wait
sunday i get the call see you monday
morning 6 a.m
huh
maybe i'm wrong
go into makeup monday morning
now we're shooting a scene with me and
jim
jim walks into the makeup trailer pats
me on the shoulder leans in and says
just keep doing what you're doing they
love you
kept walking jim carries a friend to
this day he stood up for me and and uh
he's one of the great friends i got in
this business
[Music]
hi lloyd hi harry there were moments
very few
where
jim would go off and
one of the few was
you want to hear the most annoying sound
in the world
that was
in the middle of a take what's he doing
and then he does it and then i just
repeated what he was doing because when
in doubt repeat jim you want to hear the
most annoying sound in the world
guys
and that was kind of it that was i don't
remember
other improv stuff i mean we would jim
would would try stuff and like the the
sword fight come in the blue and orange
tuxedos we we that was take seven there
were six takes before that where we
started per script
that pete and bobby had written with jim
so they kind of had already improv their
way into this we want this all three of
them so that was kind of set we did it
as written coming in uh with the orange
and blue
like that boom go in cut let's take one
take two
he does me boom boom three four five six
we do something until finally about six
or seven he goes let's have a sword
fight what do you mean yeah a sword
fight
and then we walk in
okay last take beat one more i got an
idea okay and then so jim doesn't
surprise you with it he'll say let's do
this together and so the last one was
the one they used take seven which was
sword fight come in i'll knock your head
off and then you wet me in the back
got it great boom and that
takes it we're done cut
good and they use the last one but they
had seven versions of it
which is the fun of film acting and the
fun of film acting with jim
ivan is fine but he's not a serious guy
he's a philistine
what's a philistine it's a guy who
doesn't care about books or interesting
films and things
your mother's brother ned is also a
philistine squid in the whale is a
is a father-son story and once and
certainly noah baumbach was writing
about
his own father in ways many ways he had
a father that was um
grander in his own mind than he was to
anyone else self-published i read one of
his books and it was dense as hell i
mean you could you couldn't even get
through it and yet he felt himself on a
par with people like at the you know
norman mailer others
and it's just this disillusionment
and how he kind of took some of that
bitterness and anger and rage and kind
of dumped it on his kids and
family and
it was their fault kind of thing you
know typical artist
sorry my nose is running
i'm your teacher
i wonder for a long time what it would
be like to [ __ ] you
i was surprised when
noah bomback informed me that the
student that i was going to be having an
affair with was anna paquin
going
really
because
i had done a movie with her about 10
years earlier called fly away home
when she was 12
playing
my daughter i go noah he goes i know
weeks later we're shooting the scene
and fly away home was was
a movie about
taking a whole bunch of canadian geese
and flying them south on their migratory
route and all that
and it was it's a wonderful beautiful
family film and and with the geese and
it's just
it was a really good movie i liked that
one a lot carol ballard direct that
directed that caleb dashanelle was the
dp it's beautiful movie weeks later
we're we're shooting one of the scenes
in squid in the whale and i'm up in an
upstairs bedroom with
my student with whom i'm having the
affair and it's anna paquin i have my
hands up her shirt on her breasts
the door opens and my son looks in and
sees this
and she's all of 22 and i'm 50 whatever
i am
and
and we're standing there and they're
like all right hold one second i'm
making a lighting adjustment
and anna's like looking like this i'm
like looking like this i look out the
window and i go anna look geese
[Music]
newsroom was flat out a chance to get
into television in a big way with aaron
sorkin i loved west wing i loved his
writing and uh was happy that aaron
sorkin wanted me james gandolfini was
did ghada carnage with me on broadway
and uh i i told him i said i'm thinking
of getting into television the movies
are starting to dry up and he goes well
if you're gonna get into television get
yourself a good writer i got david chase
that's what you need and i got lucky
aaron sorkin wanted me then i knew i was
okay then i knew it was in and then all
i had to do was work my ass off and and
keep it there is absolutely no evidence
to support the statement that we're the
greatest country in the world we're
seventh in literacy 27th in math 22nd in
science 49th and life expectancy 178th
in infant mortality third in median
household income number four in labor
force and number four in exports we lead
the world in only three categories
number of incarcerated citizens per
capita number of adults who believe
angels are real and defense spending in
newsroom i got to do that that now
famous speech uh infamous to some uh
that america is not the greatest country
in the world that speech came later it
wasn't in the pilot initially and about
two weeks before we started shooting
aaron said we need to see what happened
at northwestern when will went to speak
we can't just talk about what happened
in the past and so he wrote that speech
and i had two weeks to learn it uh they
he wrote rewrote a little bit changed
some numbers and this and that but that
i knew it when i got it that was the
speech that that i've been waiting 35
years to do and you got to hit a home
run with it it was shot on day three of
an 18 day shoot for the pilot there was
no guarantee we had a series even aaron
sorkin people bigger than aaron sorkin
have gotten turned down by hbo this was
a key day because on today we're gonna
find out
not only do we have a will mcavoy
but do we have a show because this is
placed in the first five minutes of the
first episode when america is still
sitting there with their remote trying
to decide whether they want to stay with
us or not so we gotta throw a knockout
punch to them in the first five ten
minutes that day number two three and
four from hbo came out
which is a set which is like an hour and
a half away from la sam waterston
munn tom sadowsky showed up sam later
said i just wanted to see if i was going
to have a job or not it was all on me
and so
i worked my ass off on it first take i
hit it out of the park i know that
because aaron walked over and said to me
after take one he goes
okay you're pitching a no-hitter i'm not
going to talk to you when he walked away
that was great then i knew i had a i had
a role i
pretty much with aaron's help saved my
career
and that everybody had a job
[Music]
i had done
purple rosa cairo with woody i kind of
was um
oh who's this guy who's this guy
and i got to to go up on this head just
to a meeting not some not an audition a
meeting with jonathan demi who at some
breakfast joint on the upper west side
of new york city and and he he you know
in that midwest straight-laced guy that
he needed for charlie driggs that was i
could i could do that in spades you know
my heroes that i leaned on at that point
were jack lemmon and dick van dyke
charlie driggs is the character is the
child of jack lemmon and dick van dyke
and demi really he really said
that we use the script as an outline i i
don't do improv i'm not good at it but
jonathan really just yeah just make up
something as you can yeah just say to
you and there was a lot of that going on
and that was an education and how to
you mean i don't have to say what's
written well what am i gonna say and
you're playing there you kind of learn
how to kind of
improv your way through scenes and
jonathan was all about that he also had
such an enthusiasm for
making movies
you could give jonathan demi 10 grand to
make his movie or a hundred million he'd
have the same enthusiasm he never
said no yeah try it let's try it yeah a
good idea don't tell me just do it i
mean he was that guy
he had such a freedom to let people just
go go do it try it we can just throw it
away go maybe it'll work that was great
i miss him i got a lot of things on my
mind you know business things and i just
i simply forgot so he deliberately
walked out without paying that check
i did not here come on take just take
the money and you know and keep the
change and fine maybe you'd like to tell
a cop
no don't no don't no don't
one of the ways that that he wanted to
get charlie drinks to be likable was to
uh
jonathan had me call people by their
names being kind to strangers you run
the risk of them being kind to you
that was charlie
so you have a waitress you call her by
her name and not superficially or
something you just and generally you
know he was he was a good person trying
to reach out and and he was friendly he
was just friendly and friendly got
charlie in trouble
is anything to worry about i mean come
on fellas
i mean do i look like the kind of guy
who would run out on a check i mean come
on
[Laughter]
you guys
[Music]
when i got the script to terms of
endearment uh
you know jim brooks wrote it
he's so smart he's such a smart writer
he took it from larry mcmurtry's book
but then brooks would do his thing on it
and so you've got two great writers that
have already been had their hands all
over this story it reminded me of doing
at that point in my career
doing a really well well-written play
and that was familiar to me i had done
some lanford wilson plays and i had done
some badly written plays
and this was not that it ain't going to
be about the writing failing so you
might want to get to work on flap and
hold up your end that's what i remember
thinking especially when you got debra
winger and shirley maclaine and jack
nicholson and
you've got some great people in this
you don't want to be you know that thing
what's wrong with this picture and
you're it
you don't want to be that guy
i'm not doing anything
yes you are i hate it when you get this
unhappy okay we go through this stage
every time no no don't change subject
what's the subject getting to play flat
horton in terms of endearment this is a
whole bunch of people passed on this
because the guy was so unlikable and in
hollywood that's that's a dirty word
certainly among the actors who passed on
it i had no problem with it you know i i
and again i think this comes out of
off-broadway in theater and you play
people
warts and all it's not until you get
into the movies and television where you
have to worry about things like being
likable and redeeming yourself at the
you know so i was i i didn't see any of
that you get to play these these
elements of human nature the successes
as well as the failings
and flap failed and so you get to
construct that and play that as if it's
your own little three-act play you know
the tragedy of flap horton i never
worried about
likeable or unlikable i worried about
trying to get him right which included
making the mistakes as big and as ugly
as they were
as as authentic as possible
i haven't
uh
really talked to the kids yet
i'm not sure how much they realize but
they know something bad is happening
flap
patsy wants to raise melanie
and maybe the boys
i think they should be with me don't you
[Music]
after purple rose and and terms of
endearment
uh even something wild came out and
nobody saw it
it was gone in two weeks from the
theaters they marketed it like a chevy
chase comedy
which it sort of is kind of until
the third act and then it goes dark
the critics didn't know what to make of
something wild and
then we were gone i did a couple of
independent movies after that
that i liked the scripts a lot one of
them nobody saw the other one didn't
come out so i needed a movie that people
saw my agent said well there's this
thing called arachnophobia frank
marshall's he's a producer he's going to
direct for the first time but it's
spielberg's company and i you know if
this is yes i'll say yes i'm in i did it
and it was it was fun it was
you know you're working with animals
and it's a bit of a horror film
but it's amblin amblin entertainment
it's spielberg it's frank it's kathy
kennedy it's the a team the crew were
all the people that worked on spielberg
movies they were now working for frank
to help frank get into the directing i
mean it was
the catering it was just oh my god this
is what movies are
this is great you know you love that and
we're on the warner brothers lot
shooting the the interior it was ah
it was great it was fun to do and great
people and then the spiders you know you
got to deal with the spiders but if that
was the only
hurdle that was that was fine i had a
great time making that
[Music]
there were a lot of uh spiders this was
early uh early 90s no late 80s
arachnophobia came out so the
animatronics the effects what is now
done on computer so well
we were just north of those those movies
where the you know
you know i mean black and white and
horrible we were just north of that on
the animatronics stuff you know they had
such a problem with shark and jaws and
nowadays
occasionally
it was best if we could use a real
spider
in this
shot
well what do you mean well
right now we're throwing a a spider
on your shirt right which is fine i said
okay to that and they
and they've got him like glued
on a fishing line and a guy's off camera
doing
like that and the spider boom comes and
lands on my shirt terrific cut great and
i go oh cut
problem was i was wearing a brown plaid
shirt
and when the spider landed
you could see them but not as well as
they wanted to
frank marshall the director came up and
said
is it possible
could we
toss the spider onto your face
okay
you want to be in movies yes i'm in it
for the glamour yes
yes
yes here's a new experience here's an
adventure go
take two boom and they get and the guy's
off there and i'm going where are they
and then whoop boom lands right there
you can feel it moving
100 2003 boom get it off go cut it
thanks jeff that's lunch everybody
that's how it went
[Music]
ross
come on
this doesn't make sense they're swarming
i've never seen them
[Music]
jack
shoot the hostage
what
take her out of the equation
go for the good wound and he can't get
to the plane with her
clear shot you're deeply nuts
on speed there was a little bit of
training not a lot we had an actual swat
guy who you know taught us how to hold
the guns going down you learn enough to
do what you're asked to do sometimes you
can go into training and
you know you know far too much and then
in the script you're only asked to do
about 10 of that so why don't you train
on the 10
and understand how to do that make sure
you get that right so that the swat guys
watching the movie in this case speed
are going yeah no that's that's how you
do it yeah that's what you want that's
all you want get up you got nowhere to
go
speed was a job every career has got
jobs and then you've got the ones that
that you really wanted and you worked
for and blah blah blah but keanu was
terrific
got to meet dennis hopper work with
dennis hopper a little bit but it was an
action movie that that i just happened
to be in
[Music]
ah
american rust is is a deep dive into
good people stuck at the bottom doing
whatever they can to survive and del
harris is one of those people the breaks
did not go their way
that doesn't mean they're bad people
they just had bad luck it happens
their dreams didn't come true and
america is full of these people and
we've tried with american rust to
draw an authentic accurate
heartfelt
yearn for these people to succeed to
have some kind of success
to have things fall right for them
finally get people to kind of lean lean
into these people
to see them bounce back
and it's a tough go you know it's a it's
a it's based on a great book by philip
meyer
it's a corner of the country that
that actually is all over this country